[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue sur LCP dans Ça vous
regarde ce soir la spirale infernale des
paris sportifs depuis le début du
Mondial de foot le phénomène explose
addiction endettement isolement les élus
de banlieue notamment exhortent les
parlementaires à mieux encadrer les jeux
en ligne alors comment freiner cette
frénésie on en parle dans un instant
dans notre grand débat avec nos invités
notre grand témoin ce soir est une des
actrices clés de la convention citoyenne
sur la fin de vie convention de 150
citoyens attirés au sort voulu par
Emmanuel Macron qui sera officiellement
installé demain comment va-t-elle
travailler quelle sera sa mission c'est
recommandations seront-elles prises en
compte la sociologue claire Touri en
préside le comité de surveillance elle
sera avec nous dans la deuxième partie
enfin nos affranchis ce soir vu du
perchoir petit par la taille grand par
le poids politique Stéphanie Despierres
nous éclaire sur le groupe parlementaire
Lyot à l'Assemblée la carte blanche de
l'avocat Bertrand Perrier sur le niveau
des élèves qui dégringole en orthographe
et puis les villes de demain def cheftel
de libération ce soir le Parc des
Princes n'a pas de prix voilà pour le
menu c'est parti
[Musique]
plus de 500 millions d'euros
figurez-vous que c'est le montant que va
atteindre les mises que vont atteindre
les mises des parieurs en France pendant
cette coupe du monde de football
l'addiction au jeu explose 4 millions de
joueurs chaque année et les plus accros
ce sont souvent les jeunes alors
qu'est-ce qu'on fait pierre Daredevil
bonsoir et merci d'être là vous êtes
députés communiste des Bouches-du-Rhône
et vous défendez une proposition de loi
pour encadrer les jeux en ligne on va en
parler largement ce soir bonsoir
Christiane Fiorina merci d'être là vous
représenter la NJ l'autorité nationale
des jeux dont vous êtes la directrice
des marchés de la conformité et de la
protection des joueurs bienvenue à vous
bonsoir Adrien Jaouen merci d'être là
vous êtes journaliste à France TV presse
et l'auteur avec Clément voyer et Xavier
piperoux d'une enquête importante pour
envoyer spécial qui a été diffusé la
semaine dernière sur France 2 et qui est
toujours disp disponible sur la
plateforme de France Télévisions ça
s'appelle paris sportifs la machine à
perdre enfin à distance ce soir Armelle
Achour est-elle avec nous ce soir
bonsoir madame Achour pas encore me
dit-on elle sera avec nous dans ce débat
elle représente sOS Joueurs elle est
psychologue je vous donne la parole dans
un tout petit instant mais d'abord
l'ampleur du phénomène on voit ça avec
Stéphane Da kowski comme tous les soirs
pour ouvrir le bal
[Musique]
si j'ai bien compris Stéphane ce soir
une détente bonsoir bonsoir
à tous Voilà je commet un père mais vous
savez que vous êtes le bienvenu allez-y
si j'ai bien compris Myriam les Français
ne sont pas très raisonnables on sait
qu'ils ont d'énormes pouvoirs de
problèmes
et en fait ils jettent l'argent enlève
c'est-à-dire que l'an dernier il y a eu
quand même 8 milliards d'euros de mise
sur les paris sportifs donc évidemment
quand on mise on espère gagner mais
regardez ce chiffre voilà ça veut dire
que sur les 4 millions et demi de
personnes qui ont gagné qui ont misé
l'an dernier sur les résultats de matchs
de foot bah il y en a 0,03% qui ont
gagné de plus de 10000 euros par an donc
en fait
là-dedans c'est que la cible donc des
pubs pour ces paris sportifs c'est
surtout les jeunes il y a 40 % des
parieurs qui ont moins de 25 ans et
c'est pour ça que la secrétaire d'État
la jeunesse tire la sonnette elle est là
très bien elle tire très bien la
sonnette d'alarme le geste est simple
hop on tire le signal donc elle l'a fait
dans le Figaro donc j'imagine que elle a
appelé le Figaro pour dire qu'elle était
prête à tirer le signal d'alarme donc
pour protéger la jeunesse moi je veux
bien la croire mais sauf que l'an
dernier qu'est-ce qui se passe c'est sur
France Info elle tirait déjà le signal
d'alarme alors ça veut dire quoi le
gouvernement se tire le signal de l'arme
tous les ans mais qu'est-ce qui fait le
gouvernement je vous sens pas très
convaincu sur la volonté je vais dire on
va quand même reconnaître que les
autorités ne sont pas restées sans agir
il y a eu des pubs qui ont été retirés
de l'antenne notamment une pub qui
prétendait que grâce au paris sportif et
ben on pouvait changer les conditions de
vie de sa famille de ses proches de sa
mère notamment regardez ce type ça vous
rappelle peut-être quelque chose
[Musique]
winamax grosse cote gros gain gros
respect donc c'est très très vicieux
l'idée qu'on pourrait donc tout pour la
daronne sa mère à l'abri du besoin donc
un peu de sociologie dans les quartiers
pas mal de familles monoparentales la
maman reste papa s'en va donc la maman
vraiment si on peut la mettre à l'abri
c'est vraiment prendre les jeunes par
les sentiments donc ça on a arrêté mais
enfin bon gouvernement pas très motivé
le plus motivé en revanche c'est
Stéphane Troussel épaisse mais PS qui
est président du conseil général de
Seine-Saint-Denis c'est le département
plus jeune plus pauvre de France donc il
se sent concernés parce que vraiment les
jeunes des quartiers c'est la cible des
pubs donc pour contrecoing contre garer
parmi les arguments des des des gens qui
fallait pas sportifs opérateurs des
opérateurs il a sa propre campagne de
pub regardez vous voyez donc il joue sur
les mêmes codes en disant sauf que quand
on joue on se ruine et donc on a tous
des chances de revenir vivre chez sa
mère ruiner que d'aider sa maman à s'en
sortir donc lui ce qui voudrait c'est
des pubs beaucoup plus strictes des
règlements pour encadrer les écoute
réduire drastiquement la publicité à
certaines heures comme l’ont fait par
exemple l'Italie ou l'Espagne ou la
publicité n'est autorisée par exemple en
Espagne contre une heure et 5h du matin
à la télé la radio
la publicité est interdite sur les
réseaux sociaux ou sur internet en
Italie et en France alors comment ça se
passe France bon c'est pas qu'on fait
rien alors euro 2021 la dernière on
avait le droit de quatre spots de pub
pour les paris sportifs là on est passé
à 3 donc 4 à 3 c'est un petit progrès
mais c'est léger quoi donc ce qui est
choquant en fait dans cette histoire
c'est que les paris exploitent en fait
on a compris la faiblesse psychologique
des parieurs alors que officiellement
ils sont enfin ils sont tenus de
dissuader les parieurs compulsifs de
perdre leur argent dans ces jeux ils
sont obligés de le faire est-ce qu'ils
le font non ils le font pas c'est la NL
qui le NJ pardon qui le dit on écoute
ils ont une obligation d'identifier les
joueurs à risque donc normalement quand
vous perdez beaucoup et que vous avez un
comportement qui commence à apparaître
pathologies qu'on devrait pas vous
proposer entre guillemets des
gratifications commerciales très
intéressantes or c'est le cas or c'est
le cas donc moi quand je me rappelle je
me dis il faut faire quelque chose
j'apprends pierre d'arrivée sur le coup
ça me rassure
on va voir ça dans notre débat merci
beaucoup merci pour ce point complet
piquant comme chaque soir revenons un
instant sur l'ampleur du phénomène c'est
la NG que vous représentez Christelle
Fiorina qui qui dit que les mises vont
dépêcher les 500 millions d'euros en
France avec avec le Mondial du Qatar
donc c'est plus c'est un record c'est
plus que l'euro 2020 et c'est beaucoup
plus que le précédent mondial de 2018
est-ce que pour vous c'est 500 millions
à là c'est déjà une forme d'échec
c'est un secteur qui est qui est en
croissance qui signifie que le pari
sportif aujourd'hui c'est quelque chose
aussi qui plaît c'est à dire que les
Français jouent on est dans une période
où vous le disiez il y avait des
incertitudes pour nous la NJ justement
se poser la question de savoir si la
flatulation si les fêtes de fin d'année
allait avoir un impact sur le sur les
mises notamment les choix d'achat des
acteurs économiques on a effectivement
dans une pratique qui est déraisonnable
dans le sens où il y a des croyances
dans le jeu et qui font qu'aujourd'hui
beaucoup de Français jouent donc 500
millions d'euros ça ça correspond
effectivement à ce qui est l'évolution
du marché en tout cas du paris sportif
ces trois quatre dernières années on est
sur une croissance à deux points on est
sur une croissance qui tourne autour de
24 25% depuis 4 ans et parce que le pari
en lui-même les offres les la
possibilité de Paris déjà et beaucoup
plus forte qu'avant on offre sur
différents championnats qui s'est
développé vous pouvez même jouer de nuit
sur des ligues sportives étrangères et
aussi parce que en fait le pari
rencontre aussi son public et le public
il est de plus en plus jeune ça c'est
frappant pierre Daredevil 72% des
parieurs ont moins de 35 ans il y a même
35% des 17 des 15 17 ans qui participent
à Paris alors que c'est interdit parce
qu'ils sont mineurs il y a même des
sites pour pour les mineurs alors qu'ils
ne parient pas d'argent mais on a
l'impression que c'est un peu
l'antichambre pour les conditionner dès
qu'ils seront majeurs à aux techniques
de de côte et de et de Paris est-ce que
le gouvernement a pris la mesure à votre
avis de l'ampleur du phénomène non
honnêtement je ne crois pas je pense que
il faut que la puissance publique elle
se met au niveau des enjeux donc c'est
pour ça que j'ai déposé cette
proposition de loi que j'ai travaillé
depuis quelques mois déjà pour essayer
de de faire en sorte qu'on prenne des
mesures fortes et une des mesures à mon
avis qu'on peut prendre c'est
effectivement de mieux réguler la
publicité alors la engie n'est pas en
jeu dans les actions qu'elle mènent elle
a je pense
honorer l'émission qui ont été qui ont
été les siennes mais je pense que on a
on mesure tous et toutes à quel point
nous sommes envahis par ces publicités
alors là il y a un phénomène en plus un
peu nouveau entre guillemets
c'est-à-dire comme c'est publicités
elles viennent à toute heure pendant un
match à la mise en un match et cetera et
cetera il y a un effet de déclenchement
compulsif c'est à dire comme ça se joue
sur un téléphone portable il faut pas se
rendre dans un endroit pour parier moi
j'ai rien contre le le jeu en soi mais
mais je pense que le le mécanismes qui
sont déclenchés sont extrêmement pervers
on va en parler d'ailleurs avec
moi je fais pour être très clair c'est
même sur les supports télévisés et
Internet d'aller jusqu'à une
interdiction de la publicité comme on le
fait pour le pétition sportive et pour
l'alcool complètement l'interdire tout
le temps les compétitions sportives mais
on pourrait peut-être envisager les
temps en tout cas il faut lancer le
débat et je propose que ça soit inscrit
dans le Code de la santé publique parce
que là on est en face d'un problème de
santé
votre texte dans un instant il n'y a pas
de profil type votre sujet votre enquête
elle s'ouvre dans un bon vieux PMU bien
français où il y a toutes les
générations
principalement des hommes d'ailleurs ça
c'est frappant et il faut quand même le
dire principalement des gens d'origine
modeste beaucoup de chômeurs alors dans
le PMU oui ce sont des gens qui sont
plutôt d'origine modeste ou classe
moyenne après je pense que dans la
totalité des joueurs qui sont ceux qui
jouent au paris sportifs il y a pas
forcément de classe sociaux
professionnels particulières par contre
dans le ciblage on est sur des ciblages
de personnes qui aiment par essence le
foot le foot c'est plutôt un sport qui
était mis dans les milieux populaires en
majorité et donc si on réfléchit comme
ça on peut se dire qu'ici les milieux
populaires mais c'est juste comme ça
qu'il faut le voir après est-ce qu'il y
a un profil type bah ce sont des hommes
il me semble que c'est 9 joueurs sur 10
sportif globalement dans les jeux
d'argent online c'est entre 85%
il y a quelque chose d'une intensité
aussi et d'une importance qu'on gagne à
chaque à chaque pari remporté alors
Armelle achourde sOS Joueurs je vois que
vous êtes avec nous je vous propose de
regarder tout de suite ce sujet signé
Marco pommier puis on en parle avec vous
juste après à quoi ressemble cette
addiction comment le pari devient une
drogue et comment les opérateurs font
tout pour l'entretenir jusqu'à fichier
et classer secrètement les joueurs sujet
signé Marco Poletti
pour les sites de paris sportifs c'est
l'exemple type du pigeon cet ancien
commercial de 36 ans s'est retrouvé à la
rue après avoir perdu son travail et
plusieurs dizaines de milliers d'euros
dans des paris sportifs pour lui tout a
basculé en 2020 pendant le confinement
une mise de 20 euros un gaine de 7600 et
quelques euros voilà et là clairement je
perds pieds c'est à dire que les mises
s'envolent c'est un peu un cercle
vicieux vous gagnez vous êtes heureux
puis forcément au bout d'un moment vous
allez perdre même si vous perdez moins
gain envie de se refaire dépression gain
envie de se refaire dépression j'ai volé
ma propre mère c'est pas moi c'est plus
médié c'est plus je suis une GT
undrouille
littéralement drogué une spirale
infernale entretenue par les opérateurs
eux-mêmes publicité racoleuses cote
attractive les sites rivalisent
d'ingéniosité pour attirer les parieurs
avec une préférence pour les perdants
tous les opérateurs ils font tous la
même chose et je veux dire on s'appelle
winamax ça veut dire gagne un max on
s'appelle bwin ça veut dire être gagnant
on fait des pubs que sur finalement la
fortune ou la chance des joueurs la
réalité elle est complètement différente
c'est que en vrai on accepte que les
joueurs perdants voilà les joueurs
gagnants on va forcément les surveiller
de beaucoup plus près et on va agir sur
leur façon de jouer d'une manière ou
d'une autre aujourd'hui si les
opérateurs détectent une addiction ils
sont obligés de proposer aux joueurs
d'arrêté des parieurs qui peuvent s'auto
exclure en s'inscrivant sur une liste
d'interdiction au jeu il arrive que des
opérateurs ne pas cette interdiction de
jeu
ou lorsqu'il voit quelqu'un qui présente
un caractère addictif et bien l'incite à
jouer plus justement pour le faire
perdre plus d'argent certains de ces
joueurs portent pleines pour cet avocat
les dossiers liés aux addictions ce sont
multipliées par 5 ces derniers mois
[Musique]
bonsoir armalachour sOS Joueurs et merci
d'avoir patienté d'abord est-ce que vous
recevez beaucoup plus d'appels au
secours c'est j'ose dire depuis le début
de la Coupe du Monde ou pas
alors non parce qu'on a constaté par
exemple pour la Coupe d'Europe que les
demandes d'aide n'arrivaient que six
mois un an après il faut vraiment le
temps que la personne sombre dans
l'addiction et soit en mesure de
demander de l'aide et ça se fait pas la
première fois qu'on joue bien évidemment
alors justement être en mesure de
demander de l'aide c'est déjà quelque
chose à quoi reconnaît-on une dépendance
qu'est-ce qui qu'est-ce quelles sont les
signals d'un basculement vers un besoin
comme une drogue
à partir du moment où on perd le
contrôle du jeu c'est à dire que le je
n'ai plus un plaisir mais devient un
besoin les joueurs le disent d'ailleurs
ils parlent d'enfer il parle de drogue
c'est vraiment le mot qu'ils utilisent
vous savez l'addiction quel que soit le
produit mais en l'occurrence le jeûne
c'est à partir du moment où on a perdu
la liberté de s'abstenir là s'abstenir
de jouer et je voudrais quand même
revenir sur quelque chose qui a été dit
tout à l'heure on a parlé des gars
marquants c'est évident que ça a une
vraie fonction
ça a une action en tout cas sur la
poursuite du jeu mais il faut savoir que
le gars Martin c'est pas forcément une
grosse somme mais on a vu notre joueur
tout à l'heure qui avait gagné 7000
euros c'est pas forcément ça ça peut
être 50 euros mais ça cramnésique ça
crée un grand plaisir d'avoir gagné
d'avoir raison le match de toute façon a
plus d'intensité quand on travailler
dessus ça tout le monde vous le dira
tous les parieurs en tout cas et même
beaucoup de sportifs qui ne feraient pas
jouer mais qui joue quand même et
également en ce qui concerne le revenu
il faut savoir que le revenu médian des
Français il était de 1837 euros en 2019
source Insee pour nos joueurs pour les
joueurs qui demandent de l'aide c'est
1425 euros de revenus médian pour les
paris sportifs c'est à dire que les
paris sportifs ils ont revenu médian
encore inférieur à ceux des autres
addicts des autres jeunes sur donc ça
touche un public en particulier on a pu
lire dans Le Figaro aujourd'hui
l'histoire de cette mère obligée
d'interner son propre fils qui avait
basculé dans cette drogue de de
l'addiction au jeu depuis ses 14 ans et
qui avait joué pour pour 30000 euros en
trois ans qu'il avait perdu on peut en
arriver là jusque jusqu'au pire il y a
des tentatives de suicide dans ces dans
ces situations là
alors c'est quelque chose
malheureusement avec lequel nous on fait
tous les jours on a affaire tous les
jours il y a effectivement des des idées
noires il y a des tentatives de suicide
voire des suicides quand le passage à
l'acte est réalisé enfin il réussit en
tout cas si on peut parler de réussite
en ce qui concerne la Suisse donc il
faut pas se leurrer et surtout je pense
qu'il y a une comment une intention en
tout cas en direction des parents je
pense au papa mais papa sportifs les
papas qui font du foot en tout cas qui
aiment le foot qui parie sur le sport
sur les marches quand ils regardent leur
le match avec leurs gamins et
malheureusement ces fréquent et c'est
fait en toute bonne conscience au
contraire c'est un moment de partage de
connivence vous voyez il y a vraiment
sympa qui se passe entre le père et le
fils le problème c'est qu'à partir du
moment où le petit lui il sait que le
papa il a joué il va dire on a gagné et
en fait c'est à partir de là que va se
créer véritablement une appétence qui va
devenir addict automatiquement mais
c'est véritablement un phénomène auquel
on assiste ce partage cette complicité
de jeu c'est véritablement une une main
entre guillemets pour ceux qui en tout
cas voudraient faire d'escalier les
voilà les joueurs ce qui est pas le cas
je vous propose de rester avec nous ça
m'intéresse d'avoir votre votre regard
sur la proposition de loi de pierre
d'arriville dans votre enquête et on le
voyait aussi dans le sujet Adrien Jaouen
vous montrer aussi que les opérateurs
entretiennent la vulnérabilité des
joueurs ça c'est complètement illégal de
faire ça ce classement secret de joueurs
vulnérables fichiers les fameux pigeons
qu'on entretient en donnant des
gratifications financières parfois alors
je pense pas que classer ces joueurs se
soient illégal par contre c'est établir
une différence de traitement pour un
service qui est égal qui là c'est
illégal en fait c'est à dire que si pour
de la même prestation de joueurs ne
peuvent avoir accès à la même finalité
là il y a un problème d'accès au service
et donc qu'on a prouvé nous dans le
sujet c'est à dire
deux joueurs qui sont classés
différemment chez un opérateur on va
essayer de prendre la même mise au même
moment sur la même cote là on va y
arriver l'autre non pourquoi on pose la
question aux opérateur il répond pas
sans doute parce qu'il a un des deux qui
est fiché comme dangereux et donc il va
forcément faire perdre de l'argent à
l'opérateur parce que l'autre ne l'est
pas encore donc il va pouvoir prendre sa
mise et
l'opérateur en question
c'est ce qu'on appelle le reportage à un
an vous avez tout à fait raison ce qu'on
appelle une imitation de mise c'est
totalement interdit sauf certains motifs
d'intérêt général impérieux et donc la
l'autorité nationale des jeux cette
année a émis des lignes directrices sur
le sujet
tu mesures de droit qui doit s'appliquer
aux opérateurs qu'il s'appliquent aux
opérateurs et qui a cessé ces pratiques
définitivement alors évidemment je peux
pas vous garantir que 100% des pratiques
on cessé il y a des tenté de joueurs
notamment qui parle encore de ces
limitations mises à la engie en revanche
le régulateur la NJ c'est saisi du sujet
ce qui signifie qui peut enquêter
contrôler et traduire l'opérateur
concernant alors c'est ça la question
est-ce que l'Autorité de régulation
fonctionne suffisamment est-ce que voilà
on a les moyens de lutter contre ce
phénomène pierre d'arrivée
moi je crois que l'autorité nationale
des jeux elle dispose d'un certain
nombre de moyens mais je pense que
globalement quand même il y a besoin
d'une prise de conscience d'un associé
pour ceux qui au niveau et peut-être
qu'on a pas mesuré jusqu'au bout la
dangerosité du phénomène qui est en
train de prendre une ampleur
considérable qui est en train
d'accompagner le développement du
mouvement sportif lui-même et je pense
qu'elle doit poser aussi un certain
nombre de questions de ce point de vue
là il y a quand même un grand marché il
y a des intérêts financiers
considérables derrière le service rendu
quand même très limité c'est le mais ils
vendent des produits
c'est extrêmement lu
[Musique]
autant peut-être de pouvoir de
contraintes qu'elle pourrait avoir
peut-être qu'il faut lui en donner
davantage je vous propose de regarder le
rôle de la publicité c'est un extrait de
votre de votre sujet pour envoyer
spécial et puis ensuite on parle des
solutions que vous proposez dans ce dans
ce texte de loi regarde
avec la bête clique bascule dans le game
première pub pour les paris sportifs
juste avant le match elle s'adresse
clairement aux jeunes
devient Nobel no game bascule dans Game
ça veut dire quoi
dans le match
vraiment le prendre plus à coeur quoi
on vivra le match de manière il y aura
moins d'intérêt si on parie pas on va on
va voir moins des moyens
alors qu'on devient en fait acteur on
dirait acteur on se voit en fait pour
eux
[Applaudissements]
en vrai c'est fait pour cibler les
jeunes quoi
alors on voudrait essayer de comprendre
avec vous Christiane fiorinat quels sont
les règles de l'autorité nationale du
jeu aujourd'hui assez assez opérateurs
et surtout concernant la publicité
qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire qu'est-ce
qu'on peut pas faire sur la publicité la
le cadre a été complété récemment
c'était en février
la aujourd'hui très clairement en
matière de publicité ce qui n'est pas
possible par exemple c'est de faire
croire un joueur que il va pouvoir
changer de vie changer de statut social
devenir riche tout simplement gagner sa
vie
[Musique]
qui a permis de la retirer cette
publicité c'est d'ailleurs la une vie
qui a décidé le retrait de cette
publicité oui absolument quand on
regarde les autres on parlait des
pouvoirs de la NJ donc la NJ elle existe
depuis deux ans
l'argile à ma connaissance leur jeune
n'avait jamais demandé le retrait d'une
publicité administrative indépendante
donc qui régule ce marché là voilà et
donc là c'est on a demandé le retrait de
cette publicités là on travaille aussi
sur d'autres publicités qui n'ont pas vu
le jour parce que en face préalable on a
tout simplement dit aux opérateurs que
ça ne pouvait pas passer par exemple au
Royaume-Uni il y a des publicités qui
sont interdites aux stars du foot ça a
été voté les l'influence des Mbappé
c'est pas possible alors qu'en France
c'est possible pourquoi on le fait pas
alors c'est un sujet on parle là des
ambassadeurs sportifs on peut parler
aussi des influenceurs c'est un peu le
même sujet qui aujourd'hui regroupe
quand même une proportion non
négligeable des investissements des des
opérateurs de jeux d'argent et de hasard
aujourd'hui il faut savoir que sur le
Mondial actuellement vous avez pris
d'une centaine d'influenceurs qui sont
mobilisés les joueurs de foot ça c'est
autre chose mais aussi les grandes
personnalités mondialement connues pour
faire un travail absolument pour faire
de la publicité sur les jeux d'argent et
en particulier le paris sportifs pendant
la phase de coupe du monde aujourd'hui
on n'a pas de cadre légal sur sur
l'affluence il y a pas de de contrat de
sisney qu'ils doivent respecter ce que
je viens bien là c'est à dire charte de
bonnes conduite chez vous alors ils
doivent ils doivent pas faire croire
qu'on peut gagner sa vie devenir riche
changer de statut social avec ils ont
les mêmes règles que les opérateurs en
revanche la NJ a recommandé donc il
s'agit de bonne pratique que les
influenceurs par exemple et signer une
charte de de l'influence responsable
auprès de la RPP on a travaillé aussi
sur les audiences des influenceurs parce
que ça c'est un vrai sujet vous avez
de faire croire qu'on peut changer sa
vie c'est interdit ça donc
si on interdit pas les publicités aux
influenceurs
la NJ on a une cellule de surveillance
et de contrôle qui exercent au quotidien
une activité de surveillance des
influenceurs mais aussi de tout ce qui
se passe sur les réseaux sociaux alors
Charles de bonne conduite surveillance
est-ce que ça suffit
moi je pense que non honnêtement je
pense qu'il faut des sanctions
existent il y a une commission des
sanctions qui est qui existe qui
d'ailleurs n'avait pas été activée
depuis plusieurs années là encore la NJ
a saisi la commission des sanctions sur
des questions d'identification par
exemple des joueurs accessifs
et donc on parlait de surveillance
évidemment à partir du moment où on voit
des des contrevenants c'est-à-dire des
publicités influenceurs opérateurs qui
dépassent les limites il peut y avoir
derrière une saisine de la commission
des sanctions et donc la commission elle
fait quoi après qu'ils sanctions on peut
mettre contre l'influenceur c'est
l'influenceur par exemple d'un rappel à
la loi jusqu'à une amende qui peut
porter sur un pourcentage du chiffre
d'affaires de l'opérateur voire là c'est
le lieu le retrait de la gréement on
sait combien d'amandes a donné la NJ
puisque c'est ce que veut savoir aussi
c'est la commission des sanctions qui
statue donc c'est c'est le
judiciaire c'est pas le régulateur et
comme je viens de le dire la commission
des sanctions n'a pas été activée ces
dernières années la NJ l'a activé la
nuit elle existe depuis deux ans l'a
donc activé cette année sur des cas sur
lesquels on a enquêté et à propos
desquels on a identifié des manquements
il y a quand même il y a 239 millions
qui ont été investis en 2021 ça je crois
que ce sont vos chiffres si je me trompe
pas sur la publicité par les opérateurs
déjà donc ça veut dire que pour eux
c'est un levier considérable de
croissance la publicité donc je crois
moi qu'il faut agir beaucoup plus fort
sur la publicité qui est un rappel
addictif en permanence on voyait les
images tout à l'heure de votre reportage
ou on est devant sa télévision et on
nous dit allez-y jouer c'est maintenant
vous vous proposez
on peut faire ça par étape interdire aux
influenceurs aux stars du foot de faire
de la pub interdire la pub pendant les
compétitions sportives ou interdire la
pub tout simplement pour toutes les
opérateurs de paris en ligne le problème
c'est que les stars du foot il y a aussi
des stars du foot à la retraite qui sont
déjà mobilisés pour partie sur et qui
ont une force d'entraînement la cité
d'entraînement donc on va rapidement
trouver les limites de de ce type de de
mesure donc moi je pense que compte tenu
des problèmes de santé publique que ça
pose je crois qu'il faut tout simplement
empêcher de le recours à la publicité
comme on le fait pour l'alcool ou le
tabac c'est je crois une addiction de
même nature et donc il faut le prendre à
ce niveau-là alors pour sOS Joueurs
qu'est-ce que vous en pensez interdire
la publicité pour les paris en ligne
comme on le fait pour pour le tabac ou
l'alcool
alors c'est très très
c'est pour ça que je pense que ça prend
du temps aussi avant de trouver entre
guillemets la bonne solution la moins
mauvaise en tout cas
il est simplement peut-être à parier
sans jeu de mots que certains joueurs
vont peut-être se diriger vers des sites
qui sont illégaux en tout cas en France
qui n'ont pas l'agrément de la NJ il
faut savoir qu'on a une déréglementation
les plus dures en tout cas en Europe
pour la en ce qui concerne la France que
la NJ a déjà fait un travail
extraordinaire qu'elle est en train de
le poursuivre
en échange assez souvent d'ailleurs sur
ces sujets mais en tout cas déjà je
pense que la première chose qu'il
faudrait obtenir c'est que au même titre
que l'alcool que le tabac est de
véritables campagnes télévisées
c'est-à-dire une pleine page à un
instant donné qui montre les difficultés
liées au jeu je pense que ça c'est au
moins le minimum avant en tout cas de
penser à l'interdiction parce que c'est
vrai qu'autrement on se dire que il y a
que l'interdiction de la publicité qui
pourrait fonctionner on a un public trop
fragile le jeu c'est pas un produit
comme un autre on le sait donc prenons
véritablement les mesures qui s'imposent
il s'agit véritablement d'un enjeu de
santé publique terre d'arriver oui donc
tout simplement tout à l'heure
j'entendais Stéphane Troussel qui
proposait déjà de commencer par
l'interdit pendant les compétitions ça
fait partie aussi que j'avais envisagé
on pourrait peut-être y aller
progressivement mais bon en réalité moi
je pense qu'on y viendra à ces mesures
là on y viendra parce que ça va faire
des dégâts tellement considérables que
voilà alors après je voudrais pas il y a
des campagnes de publicité que vous avez
que vous avez lancé je pense qu'on
envoie on envoie la télévision on envoie
sans doute sur Internet dans les
journaux qui sont très bien moi je
trouve que il y a un phénomène de
conscientisation qui est décisif et
qu'il faut faire mais j'ai peur que et
encore une fois la formule sera sans
doute un peu un peu excessive mais j'ai
peur qu'on vit de l'océan la petite
cuillère quoi sur la question de la
publicité je pense il faut revenir aussi
à ce qu'a voulu le législateur en
autorisant la publicité dans les jeux
d'argent et de hasard ce qui était notre
état aussi à la Nji lorsque nous avons
mené une concertation publique l'année
dernière sur le sujet et plusieurs
études l'idée de la publicité
aujourd'hui c'est pas de faire que pour
les opérateurs se faire une guérilla
entre eux donc d'avoir un déferlement de
publicité comme on a pu le voir
notamment au moment de l'euro l'année
dernière où là ça a été vraiment très
très puissant l'idée c'est de faire
connaître une offre légale au regard
d'une offre qui est légale et de ce
point de vue là l'objectif a été plutôt
atteint parce que si on prend le segment
du paris sportif aujourd'hui
le l'offre illégal était pléthory qui a
10 ans aujourd'hui ça t'arrive l'offre
l'offre illégale or venir jouer chez un
opérateur agréé ça signifie aussi que
l'opérateur est surveillé contrôlé par
le régulateur faire l'objet de sanctions
et que derrière le joueur aussi
possiblement peut-être protégé ce qui
est une médiation il y a une possibilité
aussi de recourir à la Nji dans certains
cas donc
publicité de
interdiction pure et dure la publicité
c'est quelque chose d'assez difficile à
manier c'est assez simple dans le dans
une majorité ici même à l'Assemblée
nationale c'est pas sûr des effets de
bord qui pourrait être dommageable
notamment en matière de d'offre illégal
pour bien comprendre les sanctions qui
sont prises de quelle nature financière
à quelle hauteur du chiffre d'affaires
pour prendre la mesure de leur
dissuasion alors les sanctions qui
peuvent être prises la plus forte c'est
le retrait de l'agrément c'est à dire
qu'on empêche l'opérateur tout
simplement de
son visageable
est-ce que c'est possible de faire ça
enfin ce sont des acteurs totalement
énorme dans le marché est-ce que c'est
possible de faire une un retrait
d'agrément à des gens comme ça c'est la
commission des sanctions qui le décident
sur la base d'un contradictoire et si
effectivement c'est un opérateur qui a
été à l'origine de plusieurs manquements
répétés grave qui ont occasionné des
dégâts en matière notamment de santé
publique parce que c'est ça qui est au
cœur de l'enjeu le juge a la possibilité
effectivement de de demander l'entrée
sanctionnée dernièrement et pourquoi la
Commission des sanctions vient d'être
saisie pour la première fois des cages
répète la NJ existe depuis deux ans et
elle exerce son pouvoir de sanction dans
ce cadre là en même temps il flirt en
permanence avec les limites on le voit
dans la publicité c'est un vecteur de
communication pour eux et de progression
il y a un but lucratif derrière il faut
jamais oublier ça il y a un but lucratif
et il se Fendt une concurrence on a
depuis qu'on a ouvert en 2010 le marché
des jeux de d'argent et de hasard je
pense qu'on a mis le doigt dans un
engrenage on va en payer le prix fort
Adrien on a l'impression quand même que
c'est un peu David contre Goliath ce
dossier il y a des stratégies de
contournement aussi avec avec d'autres
d'autres marchés avec les effets
fiscales je suis pas sûr que ce soit
David contre si l'État décide vraiment
de faire quelque chose ou si la
législation en vigueur arrive à vraiment
endiguer cette problématique là il y a
plus de David contre Goliath quoi c'est
à dire que les opérateurs ils prend plus
rien faire après moi je pense qu'il y a
une vraie question c'est de vraiment
surveiller d'autant plus près les
pratiques en dehors des publicités des
opérateurs sur la façon dont ils
traitent leurs d'autres joueurs là j'ai
vérifié par rapport au portage
certains opérateurs continuent de ficher
et d'entretenir des différences de grade
entre les bons et les mauvais joueurs
c'est à dire que les très très mauvais
joueurs pour eux ce sont des très bons
donc des fiches ils vont leur permettre
de jouer des sommes astronomiques et ça
en fait c'est aussi un truc qu'il faut
gérer là elle arrive à sanctionner ces
pratiques elle n'a pas elle n'a pas la
compétence pour ou n'a pas les on parle
de limitation
si la NJ a connaissance sur les de ces
sujets là les limitations de mise mais
pour ceux qui sont les plus vulnérables
et qui perdent tout le temps les pigeons
pour le dire vite sur les pigeons donc
on va les appeler comme tels les pigeons
les fiches comme il y a une obligation
d'une part d'identification de ces
joueurs là et ensuite il y a une il y a
une obligation pour les opérateurs de
leur faire recourir soit des modérateurs
de ne plus leur envoyer des
gratifications financières et infinie
les empêcher de jouer et donc sur ces
points là il y a des contrôles qui sont
exerc par la NJ la commission des
sanctions cette année a été saisie de ce
sujet là merci le mot de la fin très
rapidement pierre d'arriville
encouragements et puis je pense qu'on va
constater une progression malgré les
mesures que vous avez prises avec la
Coupe du Monde qui est en train de se
dérouler gratification on vient de
prendre justement des mesures sur le
sujet merci beaucoup le débat ne fait
que commencer on va évidemment suivre
l'évolution l'avenir de votre
proposition de loi dans l'hémicycle je
précise qu'on avait évidemment invité la
majorité mais pour voilà des raisons qui
voilà qui qui simplement d'agenda on n'a
pas on n'a pas on n'a pas pu on n'a pas
pu avoir un député de la majorité sur ce
plateau merci également à Armelle
achourde avoir été à distance avec nous
et rendez-vous donc le calendrier pour
cette proposition de loi donc combien de
temps pour l'instant il est pas fixé le
plus tôt possible une niche communiste
donc à venir merci à vous on va
accueillir à présent notre grand témoin
elle va jouer un rôle clé dans la
convention citoyenne sur la fin de vie
qui ses travaux officiellement demain au
Palais d'Iéna elle est sociologue elle
s'appelle claire Toury et on l'accueille
après l'invitation d'aide à mandingara
c'est un sujet qui est très intime voilà
on peut on a tous un avis sur la fin de
vie un avis on peut avoir un avis sur la
forme vie on peut y avoir été confronté
de près ou de loin donc ça touche la
secte forcément c'est aussi un sujet
sociétal qui en dit aussi sur la manière
dont on fait société ensemble sont nos
représentations collectives 150
Françaises et Français tirés au sort
pour travailler pendant plusieurs mois
sur la fin de vie avec cette question le
cadre d'accompagnement de fin de vie
est-il adapté aux différentes situations
rencontrées ou d'éventuelles changements
devraient-ils être introduit le cadre
actuel c'est la loi kless Leonetti elle
donne la possibilité d'une sédation
profonde et continue jusqu'à la mort
pour les malades atteints d'une
affection gravée incurable dont le
pronostic vital à court terme est engagé
mais les choses pourraient évoluer à
l'Assemblée une mission d'information
est lancée pour évaluer cette loi dans
son dernier avis le Conseil consultatif
national d'éthique ouvre une voie pour
une possible aide active à mourir mais
avec des conditions très strictes
Emmanuel Macron lui semble tiraillé dans
un en même temps devant Line Renaud
fervente partisanes du droit à mourir
dans la dignité il semble être prêt à
changer la loi mais après une rencontre
avec le Pape pour qui l'euthanasie est
un péché le président de la République
est beaucoup plus prudent claire Toury
vous êtes une des garantes de cet
exercice de démocratie participative
avec des attentes mais aussi des
inquiétudes pouvez-vous garantir aux
citoyens choisis que leurs paroles sera
prise en compte
[Musique]
bonsoir claire Touri bonsoir et merci
d'être là cette convention citoyenne sur
la fin de vie est très attendue des
Français quelle place précisément
aura-t-elle dans le débat de société si
sensible qui s'ouvre alors la convention
citoyenne sur la fin de vie elle
commence demain elle est organisée par
le CESU le Conseil économique social et
environnemental et à l'heure à laquelle
je vous parle il y a 173 citoyens qui
sont attendus demain donc c'est assez
énorme et alors pour répondre à votre
question il y a un débat national sur la
fin de vie qui a commencé il y a
quelques temps avec la vie du CCNE
notamment le Conseil consultatif
national d'éthique merci beaucoup et
donc ce débat national il a plusieurs
contributeurs il y a des contributions
diverses qui vont l'alimenter et parmi
ces contributeurs il y a les citoyens
les citoyens qui vont l'alimenter à
travers la convention citoyenne sur la
fin de vie qui commence demain alors
parmi ces contributeurs ça veut dire
quoi ce mot ça veut dire que leur
conclusion ne sera pas forcément prise
en compte ils ne sont qu'une
contribution parmi d'autres alors ils
sont la contrib attention parmi d'autres
je dirais plutôt ça comme ça c'est la
pierre angulaire en fait de du débat sur
la fin de vie qui est en train de
s'ouvrir forcément c'est la parole
citoyenne qui a beaucoup d'importance
après ce ne sont pas les citoyens qui
vont faire la loi et ça je crois que
c'est important de le dire tout de suite
on leur dira demain je j'en profite pour
le rappeler qu'il y a des élus de la
nation il y a des députés des
parlementaires il y a un gouvernement il
y a des gens qui sont là pour prendre
ses décisions mais les citoyens des
citoyens ils vont contribuer à alimenter
ce débat et le fait qu'il ne fasse pas
la loi ça ne veut pas dire qu'il y a pas
un cadre qui est posé un cadre de
redevabilité on peut pas demander aux
gens de donner 27 jours de leur vie
puisque c'est quand même 27 jours pour
travailler sur un sujet aussi sensible
27 jours est allé sur combien de temps
sur trois mois et demi trois mois et
demi viendront le week-end au CES œufs
Palais d'Iéna à Paris c'est ça du
vendredi au dimanche sur 9 weekends ça
commence demain du coup donc deux
weekends en décembre 4 en janvier
février puis trois en mars et donc c'est
un engagement qui a très important sur
un sujet qui est extrêmement important
et extrêmement sensible et donc on peut
pas leur demander de contribuer comme ça
redevabilité j'entends le mot mais c'est
une contribution ce sont des
contributeurs vous ne répétez pas si je
puis dire ce qui s'était passé avec la
convention citoyenne sur le climat qui a
créé beaucoup de déceptions parce que la
parole la promesse présidentielle de
reprendre sans filtre ses conclusions
n'avaient pas été tenues la loi Claisse
Leonetti sur la fin de vie est-elle
adaptée ou doit-elle évoluer grosso modo
c'est la question à laquelle les 163
citoyens tir au sort vont devoir
répondre comment vont-ils parvenir
est-ce qu'ils vont être accompagnés
d'experts est-ce qu'ils vont faire des
auditions et si oui lesquelles alors la
question c'est est-ce que la loi classe
léonétienne est encore adaptée mais
c'est pas seulement ça la question vous
avez vu c'est pas le cadre légal c'est
le cadre de la fin de vie donc ça pose
d'autres questions mais que les citoyens
identifieront eux-mêmes et donc pour
vous répondre oui ils vont être
accompagnés il y a toute une équipe
autour c'est un dispositif et
précisément sur citoyenne il y a un
comité de gouvernance que j'ai la chance
de présider mais qui est composé de 14
personnes
aussi représentant du ses œufs on a
aussi dans les représentants enfin dans
les membres du comité de gouvernance
deux représentants du Comité consultatif
national d'éthique dont son président
Jean-François delfris on a la directrice
du Centre national des soins palliatifs
et de la fin de vie des spécialistes de
la participation citoyenne des
spécialistes de l'éthique Cynthia Fleury
notamment des anciens citoyens de la
convention climat donc nous on est là
depuis deux mois et demi maintenant pour
poser le cadre et puis à ça ça ajoute
toute une équipe d'animateurs
l'administration du CESU des
communicants enfin vraiment il y a tout
un dispositif qui a été pensé décès il y
a une cellule psychologique par exemple
qui va être mise à disposition des
citoyens puisque le sujet est quand même
assez sensible et donc après c'est la
convention des citoyens dans un cadre
qui a été posé et pour pouvoir répondre
à leurs questions enfin la question qui
est posée ils vont faire des auditions
ils vont avoir accès à un socle
documentaire sauf que le documentaire
qu'on a construit pour eux voilà au sein
du comité de gouvernance et ce socle
documentaire il va être rendu public il
est sur le site internet de la
convention donc tout le monde peut y
avoir accès et voilà il y a des il y a
plusieurs auditions qui vont être
organisées les premières auront lieu ce
week-end et parmi les auditions on va
entendre à l'inclès qui viendra nous
présenter et Jean Leonetti j'imagine
alors on l'a invité mais il est pas
disponible malheureusement mais on l'a
invité donc c'est Alain classe qui sera
présent et ils ont été tirés au sort
après un comment dire une sorte de
d'enquête qui fait que ceux qui ont été
démarchés consultés ces représentatifs
de l'ensemble des Français ça c'est
important d'expliquer c'est pas juste
tirage au sort parmi la population comme
ça alors c'est pas c'est ça c'est pas
les 173 premières personnes qui disent
oui qui vont être présentes pendant 9
weekends il y a des critères
géographiques sociologiques ces critères
géographiques catégories
socio-professionnelles niveau de diplôme
l'âge le genre voilà des critères
basiques pas de critères excluants et
une fois qu'on croise tous ces critères
on a ces 173 citoyens qui représentent
la diversité de la population française
être d'accord collectivement je crois à
cette grande question doivent-ils
trouver une seule réponse ou pas je
crois pas vraiment je crois pas que ce
soit un préalable indispensable
peut-être qu'ils vont y arriver moi il
me semble que le sujet de la fin de vie
c'est avant tout un sujet de controverse
il s'agit pas de dire il y a ceux qui
ont tort et à ceux qui ont raison il
s'agit de poser ensemble les points de
convergence les points de divergence et
parmi les points de divergence
identifier ceux qui peuvent être
dépassés et ceux qui ne peuvent pas
l'être et le dire clairement je pense
que c'est ça qui est très important
quand il formuleront leur réponse alors
je sais pas quelle forme ça prendra mais
poser clairement ce sur quoi tout le
monde est d'accord et puis les questions
qui restent encore à trancher vous-même
vous êtes sociologues vous êtes
spécialiste des questions de
participation démocratie de
participative notamment pas du tout du
tout de ces sujets de fin de vie de
tanazie d'aide d'active à mourir
pourquoi vous avez accepté de diriger ce
comité de gouvernance alors moi je suis
sociologue de formation je suis plutôt
spécialiste des questions d'engagement
même pour être précis d'engagement des
jeunes mais je suis surtout président du
mouvement associatif qui est
l'organisation qui représente le monde
associatif en France et voilà quand et
je suis membre du 16e à ce titre là
c'était important que je vous soyez loin
de ce sujet professionnel c'était
important que je n'ai jamais pris aucune
position sur ce sujet c'était important
que je sois en capacité d'animer un
collectif et l'avantage de présider un
mouvement comme ça c'est le cas et puis
j'ai déjà eu une expérience au sein du
CESU puisqu'on avait travaillé avec des
citoyens il y a un an à peu près
justement sur les questions d'engagement
et de participation aux élections et
alors vous êtes garantes de quoi alors
la sérénité des débats c'est ça oui
alors je suis garante il y a des garants
qui qui sont s'appelle vraiment garant
moi je préside un comité de gouvernance
dont la mission est de s'assurer que ça
se passe bien que les citoyens trouvent
leur place qu'ils aient les réponses aux
questions qui sont posées fixez le cadre
les grands arbitrages méthodologiques je
vous le disais on a choisi de ne pas
avoir de critères excluants parmi le
panel mais on aurait pu choisir autre
chose donc on a fait ce choix là fixer
le rythme des sessions le nombre de
sessions fixées le découpage dont on
croit séquences une première la séquence
d'appropriation et de rencontres une
deuxième séquence de délibération une
troisième séquence de restitution fixer
les premières auditions et puis après
s'assurer au quotidien que le débat soit
serein apaisé dernier point l'un ce qui
est très important pour moi vraiment
j'insiste là-dessus c'est que notre
responsabilité c'est de s'assurer que
tous les points de vue sont entendus
surtout de ne pas alimenter une
polarisation de ne pas créer
d'humiliation et de faire en sorte que
voilà chacun quel que soit son
positionnement puisse être entendu de
façon équilibrée il y a beaucoup
d'instances légitime qui vont travailler
sur le sujet ici même à l'Assemblée
nationale vous avez une mission
d'évaluation de la loi classique vous
avez aussi une mission sur la fin de vie
qui va être pilotée par Olivier Falorni
ce qui est un grand militant de la
dactive à mourir il ne s'en cache
absolument pas il y a cette convention
citoyenne avec ses 173 tirés au sort et
puis il y a le comité d'éthique tout
cela sa coexiste de façon quoi égale où
il y a une légitimité qui qui est plus
importante que l'autre je chacun a son
rôle en fait je pense que si on a
aujourd'hui besoin d'une convention
citoyenne pour traiter la question de la
fin de vie ça veut bien dire que malgré
tout un tas d'espaces où il y a déjà eu
des discussions c'est peut-être pas
suffisant et donc poser les choses
prendre le temps c'est 27 jours d'une
vie un rendez-vous contre il y a peu de
gens qui peuvent passer 27 jours de leur
vie à parler d'un sujet comme celui-ci
sans être des professionnels de ce sujet
là donc prendre le temps poser les
choses poser les nuances poser les
différences les distinctions les
divergences etc c'est hyper précieux
hyper riche et ça va forcément aider la
reprise moi pour faire avancer un pays
tout entier sur ce sujet la
représentation nationale devra trancher
par la loi ou le référendum peut-être
que Emmanuel Macron n'écarte pas encore
totalement cette option nous le verrons
LCP voilà accompagnera au plus près si
possible les travaux de ses citoyens
tirés au sort claire tourisme de rester
avec nous c'est l'heure d'accueillir nos
affranchis pour leur parti pris comme
chaque soir ce soir Stéphanie Despierre
va nous parler dans Bourbon Express d'un
petit groupe de députés il s'appelle
liotte tout petit mais très puissant
d'un point de vue politique on verra
cela dans un instant l'avocat Bertrand
Perrier lui se désole de voir le niveau
d'orthographe dégringolé en CM2 et puis
fftel de libération va revenir sur le
Parc des Princes entre Paris et le
prince du
Qatar a-t-il un prix ou pas de prix ce
fabuleux stade symétique nous affranchis
les voici bonsoir à tous les trois
bonsoir et merci d'être là Stéphanie on
commence avec vous nous parlez donc de
ce groupe l IOT liotte liotte
pour liberté indépendant outre-mer et
territoire alors c'est le nom du plus
petit groupe politique ici à l'assemblée
que le grand public a découvert lors de
l'interview d'Emmanuel Macron fin
octobre sur France 2 écouter
j'ai vu en même temps ces derniers jours
au Parlement quai des députés d'un
groupe
justement intermédiaire du centre
appelle liotte qu'il y a les
parlementaires du groupe les
républicains qui n'ont pas voté cette
motion de censure ils ont donc envoyé un
message clair
nous on veut pas bloquer le gouvernement
on n'est pas prêt à tout moi je pense
qu'avec ces parlementaires là qui
aujourd'hui ne sont pas dans la majorité
le gouvernement et la majorité à
l'Assemblée a intérêt à travailler en
autant vous dire que même les députés du
groupe lot sont tombés de leur chaise en
entendant le nom prononcé par le
président en personne et moi-même j'ai
cru que j'avais mal entendu
alors pardonnez-moi je ne sais plus
quelle est ma relance pourquoi Emmanuel
Macron parle-t-il de ce groupe ce petit
groupe et bien parce que comme le dit un
député Renaissance il n'y a pas que les
républicains dans la vie il y a à
l'elliot aussi Emmanuel Macron n'a plus
de majorité absolue à la sembler alors
il cherche en permanence des alliés pour
faire voter ses textes l'Elliott ne sont
que 20 c'est peu mais ça peut servir
dans un palais Bourbon ou désormais
chaque voix compte il en manque 38 pour
avoir cette sacro-sainte majorité l'iode
s'est officiellement déclaré dans
l'opposition jusque là ils l'ont voté
pourtant aucune d'émotion de censure
alors le président de la République y a
vu une ouverture depuis ils sont très
courtisés par le gouvernement comme le
confirme Bertrand pencher le président
du groupe
encore hier soir sur la loi sur la
transition énergétique sur la sur les
énergies renouvelables la ministre
m'appelle on est embêté sur ce type
d'amendement je l'avais vu en fin de
journée de façon à faire avancer sur des
amendements qui étaient importants
on avance pas et bien le groupe ne
pourra pas ne pourra pas vous soutenir
les ministres m'appelle très très très
régulièrement la première ministre on va
la rencontrer la semaine prochaine sur
les retraites c'est la quatrième fois
que je vais voir la première milice on
est quand même beaucoup plus écoutés ils
sont très courtisés les liott alors qui
sont-ils les députés de ce groupe alors
il n'y a aucun député très médiatique ce
sont surtout des orphelins des autres
groupes mais il y a tout de même
quelques piliers de l'Assemblée
notamment Charles de Courson député de
la Marne spéciaux finances publiques
traqueurs de dépenses inutiles et pour
la gratter de Bercy chaque automne
durant la discussion budgétaire depuis
19 ans c'est un des plus anciens il y a
aussi 5 députés d'outre-mer 3 l'écorce
un Breton car dans l'yot il y a un thé
pour territoire ce sont un peu les
Girondins de l'Assemblée ardent un
défenseur de la décentralisation pour le
reste c'est un attelage politique très
hétéroclite il y a des anciens
socialistes des centristes passés par
l'UDI des régionalistes bref tout ça
donne une ligne politique non identifiée
et assez insaisissable d'ailleurs c'est
la marque de fabrique de ce groupe il
n'y a pas de position de votre commune
sur les lois chaque député fait ce qu'il
veut bon courage donc au camp
présidentiel car rien ne sert de
négocier uniquement avec le président du
groupe il faut discuter et convaincre
chaque député liotte un parent
heureusement ils ne sont que 20 oui
petit mais costauds si j'ai bien compris
merci Stéphanie Bertrand ce soir vous
nous alerter sur le niveau des écoliers
les élèves de CM2 ne connaissent ni à
grammaire ni l'orthographe oui c'est une
étude du ministère de l'Éducation
nationale qui a fait passer une dictée
aux élèves de CM2 donc ils ont environ
11 ans on leur a fait faire une dictée
de 67 mots et en moyenne sur cette mot
ils font 19 fautes c'est à dire à peu
près une faute tous les trois mots c'est
deux fois plus qu'il y a 25 ans
évidemment avec une faveur particulière
pour les fautes d'accord je vous donne
deux exemples papa et maman virgule
inquiets et bien les trois quarts des
élèves n'écrivent pas correctement
inquiets et elle les a vu c'est encore
pire 80% des élèves ne savent pas
accorder vu et au total sur tout cette
aéropage d'élèves et bien il n'y a que
2% qui font moins de 2 fautes et moi
même si aéropage alors qu'il faut dire
arrêtopage je m'inclus dedans oh il est
modeste alors les filles elles s'en
sortent mieux ou pas
21 fautes pour les garçons 17 fois pour
les filles mais là où je crois que il y
a une vraie difficulté en fait dans
cette étude c'est la corrélation qu'elle
montre entre l'orthographe et le milieu
social en réalité ce que montre cette
étude c'est que le niveau orthographique
est un marqueur social et ça je crois
que c'est vraiment la faillite de la
promesse républicaine de l'école la
promesse républicaine de l'école c'est
de décorer les savoirs du milieu social
et justement d'apporter à tout un chacun
quel que soit son milieu la capacité
d'écrire correctement un texte simple
pour demander un stage une embauche et
je crois que ce marqueur social c'est
vraiment l'échec on peut parler
d'égalité des chances tant qu'on veut
tant qu'on ne transmet pas cela et bien
ce serait des incantations vaines
quelle est la cause cette dégradation on
peut évidemment un criminer toutes
sortes de choses oui évidemment le temps
des écrans
oui évidemment le langage SMS oui
évidemment la moindre lecture mais
l'école aussi à sa part de
responsabilité à force de disperser les
savoirs d'enseigner plein de choses
intéressantes l'informatique les langues
étrangères et bien on a de moins en
moins de cours de français alors bien
sûr on fait des dictées c'est vrai mais
ça n'est pas le seul mode
d'apprentissage de l'orthographe il y a
aussi la production d'écrit la rédaction
il y a aussi l'analyse des textes et ça
on le fait moins alors ne réformons pas
l'orthographe juste pour le plaisir de
casser le thermomètre pour faire baisser
la fièvre il ne s'agit pas d'abaisser
l'orthographe au niveau des élèves il
s'agit au contraire de faire grimper les
élèves au niveau de l'orthographe car
comme son nom l'indique un élève ça
s'élève ça s'élève voilà un parti pris
mais qui reste optimiste quand même je
le sens malgré l'avertissement de
l'avocat laboratoire incarné un Bertrand
alors il va falloir relever le défi Eve
chef-elle de libération vouliez nous
parler ce soir de ce bras de fer entre
d'un côté Nasser elle que la fille celui
qu'on surnomme Mac et puis et puis la
mère de Paris tout à fait à propos donc
du Parc des Princes Nasser el Khelaïfi
qui est donc le président du Paris
Saint-Germain PSG fin novembre alors que
la Coupe du monde venait de s'ouvrir au
Qatar NAC donc a fait une véritable
déclaration de guerre à la mairie de
Paris nous ne sommes plus les bienvenus
au Parc des Princes ils font pression
pour que nous partions il joue avec nous
et nous sommes fatigués a-t-il dit à la
presse espagnole alors pourtant le
fondateur le QSI le Qatar sport
investment a acheté le PSG en 2011 et
les relations étaient plutôt bonnes
entre la mère de Paris et les Qataris
alors ça pas toujours été le cas parce
que quand en 2006 le
Qatar manifeste son intérêt pour le PSG
Bertrand Delanoé à l'époque dit on veut
pas de fonds exotiques mais aujourd'hui
c'est l'histoire ancienne les relations
sont bonnes alors qu'est-ce qui coincent
alors c'est le Parc des Princes
justement le stade qui accueille donc le
PSG depuis 1972 il y a plusieurs années
le
QSI à entomé des négociations pour
racheter l'enceinte qui appartient donc
à la ville de Paris qui lui loue pour à
peu près un minima un million d'euros
par an donc ce fond a beaucoup investi
dans le Parc des Princes et donc les
Cathar s’estime un peu légitime à
pouvoir l'acheter exactement comme l'a
dit NAC justement dans cette interview
nous avons investi 80 millions d'euros
dans la rénovation du stade mais il
n'est pas à nous qui accepterait une
situation pareille d'autant que NAC
disait vouloir encore investir 500
millions d'euros avec l'idée de IC le
Parc des Princes au niveau des grands
stades européens qui font 60 000 places
il n'en fait que 48000 donc les
négociations ont commencé et elles ont
rapidement à chauffer parce que le
ministre katari il a rend le ministre a
proposé une somme dérisoire aux yeux de
la Mairie de Paris alors comme l'a dit
Emmanuel Grégoire le premier adjoint
d'Anne Hidalgo il a dit le PSG propose
40 millions d'euros c'est moins cher que
Paredes franchement vous pensez vraiment
que le parc vaut moins que Leandro
Paredes Leandro Paredes rappelez-moi et
ben je l'ai appris juste en préparant ça
me rassure c'est ça le foot c'est un
joueur argentin et alors c'est pas fini
parce que dans l'équipe de samedi n'a
qu'à répondu à Emmanuel Grégoire alors
là dans des mots il était vraiment
vénère alors il a commencé à dire oui
lui il parle trop en face de nous il
nous dit quelque chose et dans le
journal sa version est différente s'il a
un problème on se parle en face ah oui
effectivement alors morale de l'histoire
alors d'abord Nasser el qualifie allume
clairement un contre-feu je vous l'avais
sans doute lu dans Libération le nom du
président du PSG revient dans une
affaire
nébuleuse impliquant d'ailleurs Rachida
Dati opposante numéro un diagua la
mairie de Paris c'est là où ça se
complique et dans cette affaire il est
soupçonné d'avoir voulu détruire des
documents compromettants liés notamment
à l'obtention du Mondial donc pas bon
pour l'image évidemment
sachant que pas bon pour l'image de de
l'émirates sachant que NAC donc a rend
deux ministres il y a une deuxième
raison c'est qu'il a pas digéré la
décision d'Anne Hidalgo de boycotter la
diffusion des des matchs de la Coupe du
Monde il pas de Fan Zone écran noir il
l'a dit d'ailleurs dans l'équipe il a
dit ce cathare bashing est injuste on
mérite pas ça etc si on prend un peu
plus de hauteur la relation entre la
France et les miracles étaient très
bonne sous Nicolas Sarkozy elle s'est
dégradée sous François Hollande et
encore plus où Emmanuel Macron qui s'est
beaucoup rapproché de l'Arabie Saoudite
et des airmières Arabes uniques qui sont
les ennemis intimes du Qatar et puis
souvenez-vous aussi de l'hommage à
Samuel Paty à la Sorbonne nous ne
renoncerons pas à publier les
caricatures de Mahomet le président
était allé sur Al Jazeera propriété du
Qatar exactement expliquer sa position
mais il y avait eu des appels au boycott
des produits français bref il y a de
l'eau dans le gaz à tous les étages mais
le problème c'est que si nous avons des
idées et des valeurs le Qatar lui a
aussi du gaz et en ce moment on en a
besoin donc à faire à suivre allemand
sont allés même en acheter directement
là-bas merci beaucoup elfel clair touryl
et les citoyens tirés au sort vont
garder le foot aussi de temps en temps
pour se détendre je me suis dit
au début on avait pas totalement prévu
ça et puis avec le la France en quart de
finale il va falloir qu'on organise une
petite diffusion oui donc pas de boycott
voilà ce qui planche sur la fin de vie
en tout cas les détendre merci en tout
cas d'être venu nous expliquer dans le
détail en toute impartialité bien sûr
comment va se mettre en place cette
convention très attendue des Français
convention citoyenne sur la fin de vie
merci les affranchis et à très vite très
belle soirée documentaire sur LCP avec
Jean-Pierre Gratien comme chaque soir à
demain même lui-même
[Musique]